Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. Today's episode involves crimes against children and won't be suitable for all listeners. In late 2016, a user going by the name of JasonInHell logged onto Reddit. Ranked one of the 20 most popular websites in the world, Reddit is a social, news and discussion site that features over 3 million forums dedicated to a wide variety of topics called subreddits. JasonInHell clicked on a subreddit titled Relationship Advice.
我们的节目涉及严肃且往往令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。如需获取保密支持的电话号码建议，请查看您应用中或我们网站上的本集节目说明。本集内容涉及针对儿童的犯罪，并不适合所有听众。2016年底，一位名为JasonInHell的用户登录了Reddit。Reddit是全球排名前20的最受欢迎网站之一，是一个社交、新闻和讨论网站，拥有超过300万个致力于各种主题的论坛，称为“子版块”（subreddits）。JasonInHell点击了一个名为“关系建议”（Relationship Advice）的子版块。
Since its creation in June 2009, the subreddit has amassed 6 million members with a community that boasts Whether it's romance, friendship, family, co-workers or basic human interaction, we're here to help. interaction, we're here to help. Redditors use the forum to post about their real-life relationship issues, with other users offering their guidance and support in the comments. Posts vary from small, sometimes comical misunderstandings to more serious situations. One user vents about his partner who thinks she is a cat in a human's body Another questions how they can move past the jealousy they feel towards their successful sibling Others express devastation or relief over a breakup Heavy subjects are sometimes broached
自2009年6月创建以来，该子版块已积累了600万成员，社区标语为“无论是浪漫、友谊、家庭、同事还是基本的人际互动，我们都在这里提供帮助。”Reddit用户利用该论坛发布他们现实生活中的关系问题，其他用户则在评论中提供指导和支持。帖子内容从微小、有时滑稽的误解到更严重的情况不等。一位用户抱怨他的伴侣认为自己是披着人皮的猫；另一位用户询问如何克服对自己成功兄弟姐妹的嫉妒感；还有人表达了对分手的崩溃或解脱。有时也会涉及沉重的话题。
And commenters, emboldened by anonymity, often adopt a tough love approach when providing advice. In some cases, the original poster will return to the subreddit to provide an update as to whether or not the advice they received from the community was successful. Jason in Hell published a post on Relationship Advice titled, I'm having a hard time coping with my wife having cheated on me with our neighbour. He specified that he was 30 years old, but as was standard practice on the forum, he didn't disclose any personal identifiers or the names of anyone else involved. Jason in Hell explained, I caught my wife cheating on me over a year ago. I stayed with her for the sake of our children, but I haven't been able to get it off my
而评论者在匿名状态的加持下，在提供建议时往往采取“严厉的爱”的方式。在某些情况下，发帖者会回到子版块提供后续更新，说明他们从社区获得的建议是否成功。JasonInHell在“关系建议”版块发布了一篇题为“我很难接受妻子和邻居出轨的事实”的帖子。他说明自己30岁，但按照论坛的惯例，他没有透露任何个人身份信息或任何其他相关人员的姓名。JasonInHell解释道：“我一年多前发现妻子出轨。为了孩子，我留在了她身边，但我一直无法释怀。”
mind since. Jason in hell revealed that his plight had unravelled 476 days prior to posting about it on Reddit. He knew the exact number of days, because every time he caught himself thinking about his wife's infidelity, he would tell himself, It's only been X number of days. Maybe you won't think about it tomorrow. Jason's story began in May 2015. He had just started a new, more demanding project at work that had him putting in upwards of 60 hours a week. During this stressful time, Jason noticed that his 29-year-old wife had added a password to her mobile phone. He questioned her about it and she explained she was planning a Father's Day present for him and didn't want to ruin the surprise. About a week later, Jason's wife said she was feeling
JasonInHell透露，他的困境在Reddit发帖前476天就已经开始了。他记得确切的天数，因为每当他发现自己想到妻子的不忠时，他就会告诉自己：“才过了X天。也许明天你就不会再想了。”Jason的故事始于2015年5月。他刚开始负责一个工作量更大的新项目，每周工作时间超过60小时。在这段压力巨大的时期，Jason注意到他29岁的妻子给手机加了密码。他询问原因，她解释说她正在为他准备父亲节礼物，不想破坏惊喜。大约一周后，Jason的妻子说她感到……
guilty for keeping a secret from him. She revealed that she had hired their neighbour, a 51-year-old contractor, to build Jason a home office. It struck Jason as odd that his wife felt guilty, as they'd been together for six years and she'd never once said she felt guilty about anything. As time went on, things didn't feel right. Jason's wife began using her password-protected phone more often, sometimes smiling to herself while doing so. When Jason asked what she was doing, she'd respond, nothing, then quickly put her phone away. One morning, after Jason's wife got in the shower, he managed to grab her phone before it auto-locked and required the password to access. He scanned her messages and discovered she had sent a text to their contractor neighbour that read,
因为对他隐瞒秘密而感到内疚。她透露，她雇佣了他们的邻居，一位51岁的承包商，为Jason建造一个家庭办公室。Jason觉得妻子感到内疚很奇怪，因为他们在一起六年了，她从未说过对任何事情感到内疚。随着时间的推移，事情变得不对劲。Jason的妻子开始更频繁地使用她那部有密码保护的手机，有时还会对着手机微笑。当Jason问她在做什么时，她会回答“没什么”，然后迅速收起手机。一天早上，在Jason的妻子去洗澡后，他趁手机自动锁定并需要密码访问之前拿到了手机。他浏览了她的信息，发现她给承包商邻居发了一条短信，写着：
I am all covered in frosting. You wanna lick it off. There were no other messages between them, which Jason later learned was because his wife had set up her phone to delete messages after a certain amount of time. While the text made Jason uncomfortable, he was convinced she wouldn't actually do anything to hurt him. Their neighbour began spending more and more time at Jason's house, but the construction of the home office was taking longer and longer. Unable to shake his paranoia, Jason began checking his wife's location via her mobile phone's inbuilt GPS that, when active, kept a detailed record of every place the device had gone. He noticed there were large gaps in her GPS history because she kept turning off the function. In July, Jason gained access to his wife's phone under the pretense that he needed to download antivirus software onto it.
“我身上全是糖霜。你想舔掉吗？”他们之间没有其他信息，Jason后来得知这是因为他的妻子设置了手机在一段时间后自动删除信息。虽然这条短信让Jason感到不舒服，但他坚信她不会真的做出伤害他的事。邻居开始花越来越多的时间在Jason家，但家庭办公室的建设却越来越慢。无法摆脱疑虑的Jason开始通过手机内置的GPS追踪妻子的位置，该功能在激活时会详细记录设备去过的每一个地方。他注意到她的GPS历史记录中有大段空白，因为她一直在关闭该功能。7月，Jason以需要下载杀毒软件为借口，获得了妻子手机的访问权限。
Instead, he downloaded anti-theft software, which allowed him to remotely turn on the phone's GPS while also reading all it sent and received text messages from his computer. The next day, Jason monitored his wife's phone from his computer at work. She messaged their neighbour asking to meet up, but he couldn't as he was busy at another job site. That night, Jason, his wife and their two children went out for dinner with the neighbour, his girlfriend and his son. The two women had a good time drinking, laughing and joking around. After dinner, Jason offered to look after the kids so that the two women could go see a movie together. They headed off while Jason, his neighbour and their children went back to Jason's house. The kids gathered around to play video
相反，他下载了防盗软件，这使他能够远程开启手机的GPS，并从电脑上读取她发送和接收的所有短信。第二天，Jason在工作时通过电脑监控妻子的手机。她给邻居发信息约见面，但他因为在另一个工地忙而无法赴约。那天晚上，Jason、他的妻子和他们的两个孩子与邻居、他的女友及其儿子一起出去吃饭。两个女人喝得很开心，有说有笑。晚饭后，Jason主动提出照顾孩子，让两个女人一起去看电影。她们出发了，而Jason、邻居和孩子们回到了Jason家。孩子们聚在一起玩视频……
games as Jason and his neighbour sat on adjacent couches. Jason inconspicuously kept an eye on his wife's mobile phone activity. She began texting the neighbour about the sex acts she wanted to perform with him. She then sent him an explicit photo of herself in a bathroom stall. They continued to message back and forth, trying to figure out when they could meet up to have sex. They settled on Monday morning after Jason went to work. Jason was barely able to keep his composure as he spied on their interactions in real time while his neighbour sat across from him none the wiser. When the pair texted that they
游戏，而Jason和邻居坐在相邻的沙发上。Jason不动声色地盯着妻子的手机动态。她开始给邻居发短信，描述她想和他进行的性行为。然后，她给他发了一张自己在卫生间隔间里的露骨照片。他们继续来回发信息，试图确定什么时候可以见面发生性关系。他们定在Jason去上班后的周一早上。当Jason坐在邻居对面，实时窥探他们的互动，而邻居却一无所知时，他几乎无法保持镇定。当两人发短信说他们……
loved each other, Jason was suddenly overcome with the urge to leap off the couch and knock the other man out, but he managed to contain his emotions. the other man out, but he managed to contain his emotions. You're my girl now, his neighbour texted his wife. Always have been, his wife replied. Then she received the final text from him. Always will be. When the two women returned from the movie, Jason asked them politely to sit down.
彼此相爱时，Jason突然有一种冲动，想从沙发上跳起来把那个人打昏，但他设法控制住了自己的情绪。“你现在是我的女孩了，”邻居给他的妻子发短信。“一直都是，”妻子回复道。然后她收到了他发来的最后一条短信：“永远都会是。”当两个女人看完电影回来时，Jason礼貌地请她们坐下。
He then sent the children into his son's room and shut the door. So you two love each other, huh? he asked. His wife went into what Jason described as full-blown denial mode. Jason's wife denied that she had been texting their neighbour. When Jason showed her the text messages from that night, she buckled, admitting that she did send them, but it was the first time their interactions had gone that far. Jason then asked his wife if she had sent the man pictures. She said no, so Jason showed her the explicit picture she took of herself in the bathroom store. Once again, his wife backtracked and accepted responsibility, though insisted it was the first photo she'd ever sent.
然后他让孩子们去儿子的房间并关上了门。“所以你们两个相爱了，是吗？”他问。他的妻子进入了Jason所描述的“全面否认模式”。Jason的妻子否认她曾给邻居发过短信。当Jason给她看那天晚上的短信时，她崩溃了，承认她确实发了，但这是他们第一次互动到那种程度。Jason随后问妻子是否给那个人发过照片。她说没有，于是Jason给她看了她在卫生间拍的那张露骨照片。妻子再次改口并承担了责任，尽管坚称这是她发过的第一张照片。
Jason outright asked his wife if she was having sex with the neighbour. She said no, and Jason couldn't prove otherwise. To Jason's surprise, his neighbour's girlfriend appeared more forgiving, saying that the fling couldn't have been serious if their partners hadn't had sex. She went on to say that Jason and his wife were too perfect together to let the affair break them up. She and the neighbour soon left. Jason told his wife that he was leaving her, which prompted her to threaten that he would never see their kids again. Jason wrote on Reddit, that he would never see their kids again.
Jason直接问妻子是否与邻居发生了性关系。她说没有，而Jason无法证明事实并非如此。令Jason惊讶的是，邻居的女友似乎更宽容，说如果他们的伴侣没有发生性关系，这段恋情就不可能是认真的。她接着说，Jason和她妻子在一起太完美了，不能让这段婚外情拆散他们。她和邻居很快就离开了。Jason告诉妻子他要离开她，这促使她威胁说他将永远见不到他们的孩子。Jason在Reddit上写道，他将永远见不到他们的孩子。
Jason wrote on Reddit, She planned on using the fact that I had attempted suicide in high school to prove me unfit to have the children. His wife then blamed him for her infidelity, saying it was his fault for being so busy and stressed out with work. She had just wanted someone she could talk to. She then gave Jason an ultimatum, decide what he was going to do next or she would decide for him. The couple spent the night arguing and wound up in separate beds with nothing resolved. The fight continued over the weekend until they ultimately
Jason在Reddit上写道：“她打算利用我在高中时曾试图自杀的事实来证明我不适合抚养孩子。”他的妻子随后将她的不忠归咎于他，说是他工作太忙、压力太大造成的。她只是想找个能说话的人。然后她给Jason下了最后通牒：决定下一步怎么做，否则她会替他决定。这对夫妇争吵了一整晚，最终分房睡，问题没有得到解决。争吵持续了整个周末，直到他们最终……
decided to separate temporarily while they figured out what they wanted. Jason was going to stay at the family home while his wife took their kids to her mother's place. That Monday, Jason was in a work meeting when he received a text from his wife saying she had explained the situation to their kids. They were upset and she wanted Jason to talk to them. When he returned home, both of the children were crying. His wife had told them that mummy had to move out because dad was mad at her. them that mummy had to move out because dad was mad at her. Their son wanted to live with Jason, but Jason's wife said that he couldn't. The boy had interpreted this to mean that Jason must have been mad at him too. Jason realised that his wife was going to, quote, drag the kids through hell if he left.
决定暂时分居，同时弄清楚他们想要什么。Jason打算留在家里，而他的妻子带着孩子去她母亲家。那个周一，Jason正在开会时收到妻子的短信，说她已经向孩子们解释了情况。他们很难过，她想让Jason和他们谈谈。当他回到家时，两个孩子都在哭。他的妻子告诉他们，妈妈必须搬出去，因为爸爸生她的气。他们的儿子想和Jason住在一起，但Jason的妻子说他不能。男孩把这理解为Jason一定也在生他的气。Jason意识到，如果他离开，他的妻子会“带着孩子们下地狱”。
Instead, he bottled up his feelings and begged her to stay. She agreed, but insisted that he apologise to their neighbour for the sake of their sons, who were good friends. Although Jason hated the idea, he did it anyway as they would inevitably continue to cross paths. He would do anything for his kids, even acting civil in such distressing and emotionally crippling circumstances.
相反，他压抑了自己的感情，恳求她留下来。她同意了，但坚持要求他为了儿子的缘故向邻居道歉，因为他们是好朋友。尽管Jason讨厌这个主意，但他还是照做了，因为他们不可避免地会继续碰面。他愿意为孩子们做任何事，即使是在这种令人痛苦和情感崩溃的情况下表现得客气。
After this, things seemingly settled down, but Jason was constantly plagued by thoughts of his wife's infidelity. I worry, how can I keep from making her so unhappy that she cheats on me again, he wrote on Reddit. Then, a year after the original incident, Jason discovered that his wife had sent the neighbour lewd photos of herself again. She claimed it was an accident and that she had intended to send them to Jason. Although he didn't believe her, he moved on. Jason concluded his Reddit post by writing that things had been quiet on that front for about four months, but he continued to think about it all the time. This is going to sound stupid, he wrote, but I feel like I have a part of my brain that can't shut off, that is always thinking.
此后，事情似乎平静了下来，但Jason一直被妻子不忠的想法所困扰。“我很担心，我该如何避免让她如此不快乐以至于她再次出轨？”他在Reddit上写道。然后，在最初的事件发生一年后，Jason发现妻子再次给邻居发了她自己的淫秽照片。她声称这是一个意外，她本打算发给Jason。虽然他不相信她，但他还是选择了继续生活。Jason在Reddit帖子的结尾写道，在那方面已经平静了大约四个月，但他一直都在想这件事。“这听起来很蠢，”他写道，“但我感觉我的大脑里有一部分无法关闭，一直在思考。”
I used to use that to solve programming problems and it made me very good at my job. But ever since this incident, the only thing it thinks about is her and him and if I did the right thing. My job performance has suffered and I feel like I haven't gotten sleep in months. I'm afraid that after this much time and the fact that I begged her back, that to say that I want a divorce now would only make her more vindictive towards my children and I. I just feel like I have to put myself so deep in a hole that I can never get back out. I haven't really talked to anyone about this. I tried talking to one friend about it, but his advice was to put my trust in God. That was not much solace for me as I am an atheist. So I have no clue what to do with my feelings or how to move on from this.
“我过去常利用这一点来解决编程问题，这让我在工作中表现出色。但自从这件事发生后，它唯一想的就是她和他，以及我是否做了正确的事。我的工作表现受到了影响，我觉得我已经好几个月没睡过觉了。我担心经过这么长时间，加上我恳求她回来的事实，现在说我想离婚只会让她对我和孩子们更加怀恨在心。我只是觉得我把自己困在了一个深坑里，永远无法爬出来。我没有真正和任何人谈过这件事。我试着和一个朋友谈过，但他的建议是让我相信上帝。这对我也没什么安慰，因为我是个无神论者。所以我不知道该怎么处理我的感受，也不知道该如何从中走出来。”
Jason in Hell's post to the Relationship Advice subreddit received over 200 comments from users all around the world offering their input and support. The top comment had upwards of 500 upvotes, signifying that a large number of users had rated it positively. Written by someone with the username Monsieur Le Dude, it advised the Jason in Hell not to navigate the situation alone and to seek legal counsel as soon as possible. Monsieur Le Dude, it advised the Jason in Hell not to navigate the situation alone and to seek legal counsel as soon as possible. You won't be doing your children any favours by remaining in a marriage that is now founded on lies, infidelity and outright bullying, the user wrote. Other commenters agreed that Jason in hell should obtain a lawyer and divorce his wife. Many were outraged at his willingness to placate her by apologising to the man she had an affair with and begging her to stay.
JasonInHell在“关系建议”子版块的帖子收到了来自世界各地用户的200多条评论，提供了他们的意见和支持。置顶评论获得了超过500个赞，表明大量用户对其给予了正面评价。该评论由用户名为Monsieur Le Dude的人撰写，建议JasonInHell不要独自应对这种情况，并尽快寻求法律咨询。“如果你继续维持一段建立在谎言、不忠和公然欺凌基础上的婚姻，你对你的孩子没有任何好处，”该用户写道。其他评论者也同意JasonInHell应该找律师并与妻子离婚。许多人对他愿意通过向他妻子出轨的对象道歉并恳求她留下来来安抚她感到愤怒。
Smack the shit out of that man, one user demanded. Others were angry that Jason's wife was blackmailing him by threatening to use his suicide attempt 15 years prior to get full custody of their children. One user called her tactics, quote, "...incredibly low and fucked up." Advice was also given on how Jason should navigate the legal system should he wind up having to fight for the custody of his children. The user 2012mustanggt wrote, This dude's kids will someday understand the sacrifices he is making in his own life to keep them ignorantly happy. User porkbellydiet wrote to Jason,
“狠狠地揍那个人一顿，”一位用户要求道。其他人对Jason的妻子通过威胁利用他15年前的自杀未遂来获得孩子完全监护权而勒索他感到愤怒。一位用户称她的策略“极其卑劣且恶心”。关于Jason如果最终不得不为争取孩子监护权而进行法律斗争时该如何应对法律体系，也给出了建议。用户2012mustanggt写道：“这个人的孩子们终有一天会明白他为了让他们在无知中快乐而在自己生活中做出的牺牲。”用户porkbellydiet写给Jason：
Please know your worth and best of luck to you and your children. Almost a week after his initial post, Jason in Hell reappeared on the subreddit. In a brief update titled, I'm taking your advice, Jason revealed that his wife didn't want to attempt to fix their relationship and refused to undergo counselling. He wrote, I am going to get myself and my kids out. I meet with an attorney next week. Thank you everyone for helping me see how far I had my head up my arse. for helping me see how far I had my head up my arse." Jason's update received only 20 comments, all of which were overwhelmingly positive. Users reassured him that he was doing the right thing. Monsieur Le Dut, who had encouraged Jason to seek legal counsel in the initial post,
“请了解你的价值，祝你和你的孩子们好运。”在最初发帖近一周后，JasonInHell再次出现在子版块。在一篇题为“我听从了你们的建议”的简短更新中，Jason透露他的妻子不想尝试修复他们的关系，并拒绝接受咨询。“我要带我和孩子们离开。我下周会见律师。谢谢大家帮我看到我之前有多么愚蠢。”Jason的更新只收到了20条评论，全部都是压倒性的正面评价。用户们向他保证他做出了正确的决定。在最初的帖子中鼓励Jason寻求法律咨询的Monsieur Le Dude，
wrote, Good for you and good luck. Remember that life on the other side of all this will be far better for both yourself and your children, and let that hope keep you going when things get rough. Jason and Brandy Worley were engaged for two years before tying the knot in 2009. Their first child, a son named Tyler, was born that same year. Then in 2013, the couple welcomed their second child, a daughter they named Charlie. Both Jason and Brandy agreed that they would always put their children first above all else, including their marriage. The family of four lived in the small midwestern town of Darlington, Indiana.
写道：“为你感到高兴，祝你好运。记住，这一切之后的生活对你和你的孩子来说都会好得多，让这种希望在你感到艰难时支撑你走下去。”Jason和Brandy Worley在2009年结婚前订婚了两年。他们的第一个孩子，一个名叫Tyler的儿子，同年出生。然后在2013年，这对夫妇迎来了他们的第二个孩子，一个他们取名为Charlie的女儿。Jason和Brandy都同意，他们会永远把孩子放在第一位，高于一切，包括他们的婚姻。这个四口之家住在印第安纳州达灵顿的一个小镇上。
With a population of less than a thousand residents, most knew the Walleys and considered them good people. Wednesday November 16 2016 was a typical day for the family. Jason went to his job as a software engineer, while Brandy took seven-year-old Tyler and three-year-old Charlie to spend their day with their grandmother. That evening, they all attended one of Charlie's dance performances before returning home for dinner. Brandy then ducked out to Walmart to buy some pipe cleaners for a project Tyler was working on for school. When she returned home, she joined Jason in playing with their children in the living room. Jason then bathed and put both Tyler and Charlie to bed before retiring for the night.
人口不到一千人，大多数人都认识Worley一家，并认为他们是好人。2016年11月16日星期三对这个家庭来说是典型的一天。Jason去做了软件工程师的工作，而Brandy带着7岁的Tyler和3岁的Charlie去祖母家度过了一天。那天晚上，他们都参加了Charlie的舞蹈表演，然后回家吃晚饭。Brandy随后溜出去沃尔玛买了一些管道清洁剂，用于Tyler学校的一个项目。当她回到家时，她和Jason一起在客厅里陪孩子们玩耍。Jason随后给Tyler和Charlie洗了澡并哄他们上床睡觉，然后自己也休息了。
As it neared 5am, Jason woke to the sound of screaming. He rushed upstairs to find his mother-in-law crying hysterically in the kitchen. Brandy was sitting in the nearby living room, bleeding profusely from a wound in her neck. Now you can't take my children from me, she told Jason. Minutes earlier, at 4.35am, a phone call was placed to 911. The dispatcher was left speechless by what he heard and was convinced the caller must have been delusional and lying. In what town? Darlington. Hey, what's going on there? I just stabbed myself and I killed my two children. You stabbed yourself and killed your two children?
临近凌晨5点，Jason被尖叫声惊醒。他冲上楼，发现岳母在厨房里歇斯底里地哭泣。Brandy坐在附近的客厅里，脖子上的伤口血流不止。“现在你不能把我的孩子从我身边带走了，”她对Jason说。几分钟前，即凌晨4点35分，有人拨打了911。调度员被他听到的内容惊呆了，并确信打电话的人一定是产生了幻觉且在撒谎。“在哪个镇？”“达灵顿。”“嘿，那里发生了什么事？”“我刚刚刺伤了自己，我杀死了我的两个孩子。”“你刺伤了自己并杀死了你的两个孩子？”
Mm-hmm. Okay, and what's your name? Randy Orley. And where are the children at? In my daughter's room on the floor. In your daughter's room on the floor. In your daughter's room on the floor? Okay. And what caused you to do this today? My husband wanted a divorce. I wanted to take my kids. I don't want him on my kids. Okay. And how old are your children? 7 and 3 10 and 3
“嗯哼。”“好的，你叫什么名字？”“Brandy Worley。”“孩子们在哪里？”“在我女儿的房间地板上。”“在你女儿的房间地板上。在你女儿的房间地板上？好的。今天是什么原因让你这么做？”“我丈夫想要离婚。我想带走我的孩子。我不想要他带走我的孩子。”“好的。你的孩子多大了？”“7岁和3岁。”“10岁和3岁？”
7 7 and 3 mhm ok and where did you stab yourself at in the neck Where did you stab yourself at? In the neck.
“7岁和3岁。”“嗯哼，好的。你刺伤了自己哪里？”“在脖子上。”“你刺伤了哪里？”“在脖子上。”
Okay, are you bleeding? Yeah, I've been bleeding everywhere. Okay, and where are you at? In the living room. You're in your living room? Mm-hmm. Okay. Okay.
“好的，你在流血吗？”“是的，我到处都在流血。”“好的，你在哪里？”“在客厅里。”“你在客厅里？”“嗯哼。好的。好的。”
Are you armed now with a knife still? No, it's in my children's room. Okay. Where's your husband at? Downstairs somewhere. Okay, where's your husband at? Downstairs somewhere. Okay, what's his condition? I don't know. I don what's his name? Jason. Jason? Jason Worley?
“你现在手里还有刀吗？”“没有，它在孩子们的房间里。”“好的。你丈夫在哪里？”“在楼下某个地方。”“好的，你丈夫在哪里？”“在楼下某个地方。”“好的，他的情况如何？”“我不知道。我不知道他叫什么名字？”“Jason。”“Jason？Jason Worley？”
Yeah. When police arrived at the Worley house, they found Tyler and Charlie deceased in Charlie's bedroom. Brandy Worley was sitting on a couch in the living room. She was rushed to hospital where she remained for over a week, during which her neck wound was successfully treated. When police were finally able to speak to Brandy, it was the first time the lifelong Darlington resident had come to the attention of authorities. She had no prior criminal history and there was no evidence that her children were in any danger prior to November 17. To the contrary, the Worley family was widely described as happy and loving. Yet, Brandy told investigators that after seven years together on Wednesday November 16, Jason had filed for divorce. Citing irretrievable breakdown of their marriage following Brandy's infidelity a year prior,
“是的。”当警察到达Worley家时，他们发现Tyler和Charlie在Charlie的卧室里已经死亡。Brandy Worley坐在客厅的沙发上。她被紧急送往医院，在那里待了一周多，期间她脖子上的伤口得到了成功治疗。当警察最终能够与Brandy交谈时，这是这位终身居住在达灵顿的居民第一次引起当局的注意。她没有犯罪记录，也没有证据表明在11月17日之前她的孩子处于任何危险之中。相反，Worley一家被广泛描述为幸福和充满爱心的家庭。然而，Brandy告诉调查人员，在他们在一起七年后的11月16日星期三，Jason提出了离婚。由于Brandy一年前的不忠导致婚姻无法挽回地破裂，
he was no longer able to stay together for the sake of their children. As part of the divorce agreement, he had requested custody and child support benefits with equitable division of the family assets. That evening, instead of buying pipe cleaners from Walmart, Brandy purchased a K-bar style combat knife which she hid in her son's room. Once everyone was in bed, she consumed large quantities of the antihistamine Benadryl in order to make herself drowsy. She then entered Tyler's bedroom and stirred him awake, saying they were going to have a sleepover in his little sister's room. She retrieved the combat knife and followed Tyler out.
他无法再为了孩子而维持这段婚姻。作为离婚协议的一部分，他要求获得监护权和子女抚养费，并公平分割家庭资产。那天晚上，Brandy没有从沃尔玛买管道清洁剂，而是买了一把K-bar式战斗刀，并把它藏在儿子的房间里。大家都睡下后，她服用了大量的抗组胺药苯海拉明，让自己昏昏欲睡。然后她走进Tyler的卧室，把他叫醒，说他们要去他妹妹的房间里过夜。她拿上战斗刀，跟着Tyler走了出去。
Once inside Charlie's bedroom, Brandy straddled her son and began stabbing him in the neck. Charlie woke up to the commotion and asked her mother what she was doing. Through the darkness, Brandy responded, nothing, go back to sleep. Brandy then approached Charlie and stabbed her in the neck multiple times before inserting the knife into her own neck. Leaving the knife in her daughter's room, a bleeding Brandy then made her way to the living room, where she picked up the phone and called her mother to tell her what she'd done. Brandy's mother ordered her to call 911. Brandy's mother ordered her to call 911. Brandy did as she was told and was still speaking with the 911 dispatcher when her mother arrived and entered Charlie's room to find the two children deceased.
进入Charlie的卧室后，Brandy跨坐在儿子身上，开始刺向他的脖子。Charlie被骚动惊醒，问妈妈在做什么。在黑暗中，Brandy回答说：“没什么，回去睡觉吧。”Brandy随后走向Charlie，多次刺向她的脖子，然后将刀插入自己的脖子。将刀留在女儿房间后，流着血的Brandy走到客厅，拿起电话打给母亲，告诉她自己做了什么。Brandy的母亲命令她拨打911。Brandy的母亲命令她拨打911。Brandy照做了，当她母亲赶到并进入Charlie的房间发现两个孩子已经死亡时，她还在和911调度员通话。
It was her scream that woke up Jason Worley, who had been sleeping soundly in the basement. Brandy told the police that she had intended to kill herself but had somehow, quote, screwed that up. Matter-of-factly, she explained that she didn't want her divorcing husband to take their kids from her, so she stabbed them. I just wanted to die with them, she revealed. I didn't want them to live without me. The outpouring of grief from the local community was immense. Councillors were called in to speak to devastated students at Tyler's elementary school, while neighbours of the Worleys were left in disbelief. They couldn't fathom that such a horrific crime could happen
正是她的尖叫声惊醒了在地下室熟睡的Jason Worley。Brandy告诉警察，她本打算自杀，但不知何故，“搞砸了”。她实事求是地解释说，她不想让要离婚的丈夫把孩子从她身边带走，所以她刺伤了他们。“我只是想和他们一起死，”她透露。“我不想让他们没有我而活。”当地社区的悲痛之情溢于言表。心理咨询师被请来与Tyler小学里悲痛欲绝的学生们交谈，而Worley一家的邻居们则感到难以置信。他们无法想象如此可怕的罪行竟然会发生在
to a seemingly normal family, one that often hosted get-togethers and bonfires on holidays. Brandy appeared to be a doting mother. She was often seen walking her two children around the neighbourhood and photos of them featured throughout her personal Facebook page, on which she wrote, In the end, I am the only one that can give my children a happy mother that loves life. Some who knew Brandy regarded her as a great person. They couldn't comprehend a sight of her that would compel her to kill her own children. couldn't comprehend a sight of her that would compel her to kill her own children.
一个看似正常的家庭身上，一个经常在节日里举办聚会和篝火晚会的家庭。Brandy看起来是一位慈爱的母亲。她经常被看到带着两个孩子在社区里散步，他们的照片出现在她个人Facebook页面的各个角落，她在上面写道：“最后，只有我能给我的孩子一个热爱生活的快乐母亲。”一些认识Brandy的人认为她是一个很好的人。他们无法理解她身上竟然会有迫使她杀死自己亲生孩子的一面。
An online fundraiser was launched to support Jason Worley and help pay for his children's funeral. Tyler and Charlie were laid to rest under a shared tombstone that read, Rest well sweet babies. Dad loves you. Etched next to Tyler's name was a Rowlet, an owl-like creature from the series Pokemon. Charlie's name was accompanied by the snowman Olaf from the Disney film Frozen. Despite a cleaning crew having since been through the Worley home, Jason noticed his daughter's room still raked of blood. Unable to stay there any longer, he gathered some of his possessions and threw them into the back of a van. For the murders of her two children, Brandy Worley initially entered a not guilty plea with the intention of claiming the insanity defence. However, she ultimately accepted a plea deal and altered her plea to guilty to avoid facing a trial. Brandy's defence attorney claimed there was no definitive reason why the murders
一个在线筹款活动被发起，以支持Jason Worley并帮助支付他孩子的葬礼费用。Tyler和Charlie被安葬在一块共享的墓碑下，上面写着：“安息吧，可爱的宝贝们。爸爸爱你们。”Tyler的名字旁边刻着Rowlet，这是《精灵宝可梦》系列中的一种猫头鹰生物。Charlie的名字旁边是迪士尼电影《冰雪奇缘》中的雪人Olaf。尽管清洁队已经清理过Worley的家，但Jason注意到女儿的房间里仍然弥漫着血腥味。无法再待在那里，他收拾了一些财物，扔进了货车的后部。对于谋杀两个孩子的罪行，Brandy Worley最初提出了无罪抗辩，打算以精神错乱为由进行辩护。然而，她最终接受了认罪协议，并将抗辩改为有罪，以避免面对审判。Brandy的辩护律师声称，没有明确的原因说明谋杀
took place. As others had described, Brandy was a wonderful, caring mother, but her lawyer said she simply snapped. He wanted to give the court an explanation, but conceded, I can't do that. He said that Brandy had been emotional during their first few meetings, but as time wore on, she became more stoic, as that's the only way she can deal with it at this point. Her lawyer also revealed that since the murders, Brandy had been diagnosed with depression. In 2018, Jason Worley took the stand during Brandy's sentencing hearing, telling the court that his children were his life. He described seven-year-old Tyler as a loving, energetic first grader who
为何发生。正如其他人所描述的那样，Brandy是一位出色的、充满爱心的母亲，但她的律师说她只是“崩溃了”。他想给法庭一个解释，但承认：“我做不到。”他说Brandy在他们最初的几次会面中情绪激动，但随着时间的推移，她变得更加冷漠，因为这是她目前唯一能应对的方式。她的律师还透露，自谋杀案发生以来，Brandy被诊断出患有抑郁症。2018年，Jason Worley在Brandy的量刑听证会上出庭作证，告诉法庭他的孩子就是他的生命。他描述7岁的Tyler是一个充满爱心、精力充沛的一年级学生，
loved sports. The type of child who could walk into a room of strangers and walk out with 20 new friends. He wanted to work on computers one day like his dad. Three-year-old Charlie was a big ball of attitude who loved getting dressed up and wouldn't leave the house without braids or a bow in her hair. Jason's divorce to Brandy had been finalised in March 2017 and they hadn't spoken since the night of the murders. In regards to his ex-wife's guilty plea, Jason said, She appeared to be just as unremorseful as she did in the 911 call. When asked what sentence he would like to see Brandy receive, Jason responded, When asked what sentence he would like to see Brandy receive, Jason responded,
热爱运动。那种可以走进一个满是陌生人的房间，然后带着20个新朋友走出来的孩子。他想有一天像他爸爸一样从事计算机工作。3岁的Charlie是一个充满个性的“小球”，喜欢打扮，不扎辫子或戴蝴蝶结就不出门。Jason与Brandy的离婚于2017年3月最终敲定，自谋杀案发生的那晚起，他们就再也没有说过话。关于前妻的认罪，Jason说：“她看起来和在911电话里一样毫无悔意。”当被问及他希望Brandy受到什么判决时，Jason回答说：
All I want and have ever wanted was prison for the murders of Tyler and Charlie. Brandy remained silent upon hearing the outcome. She was twice asked if she had anything to say, but she opted not to make a statement. not to make a statement. The judge acknowledged that people wanted an explanation as to how a loving mother could kill her own children, but told the court, Sometimes there is no explanation. Darkness is in this world, and it penetrates minds and our hearts. In the week after Tyler and Charlie Worley were murdered, a post was made on the
“我想要且一直想要的，就是让她为谋杀Tyler和Charlie入狱。”Brandy在听到结果时保持沉默。她两次被问及是否有话要说，但她选择不发表声明。法官承认人们想要一个解释，说明一位慈爱的母亲怎么会杀死自己的孩子，但告诉法庭：“有时没有解释。黑暗存在于这个世界上，它渗透进我们的思想和心灵。”在Tyler和Charlie Worley被谋杀后的一周内，一篇帖子出现在
subreddit dedicated to American news commenter and YouTube personality Philip DeFranco. Titled, A Message for Phil, the author was a Redditor going by the username JasonInHell. He wrote, username JasonInHell. He wrote, My name is Jason Worley. I have watched Phil for several years now and his words have always brought me comfort in times of great loss. Last Thursday I lost my children, Tyler age 7 and Charlie age 3, in horrific tragedy. Jason didn't elaborate any further and instead went on to write of his children's love of Phil's work. Any kind words you can offer would be greatly appreciated, Jason requested, before encouraging Phil to hold his own baby son close.
致力于美国新闻评论员和YouTube名人Philip DeFranco的子版块上。标题为“给Phil的一条信息”，作者是一位用户名为JasonInHell的Reddit用户。他写道：“我的名字是Jason Worley。我已经看了Phil的节目好几年了，他的话总是在我遭受巨大损失时给我带来安慰。上周四，我在一场可怕的悲剧中失去了我的孩子，7岁的Tyler和3岁的Charlie。”Jason没有再多做解释，而是继续写道他的孩子们对Phil工作的喜爱。“如果你能提供任何善意的话，我将不胜感激，”Jason请求道，并鼓励Phil紧紧拥抱他自己的宝贝儿子。
The post flew under Philip DeFranco's radar, but his audience took notice and looked into Jason's Reddit profile, where they came across his previous posts seeking advice about his cheating wife. Jason initially said he was staying with his wife for the sake of his children, but users unanimously told him to divorce her. He expressed gratitude for the advice which he intended to follow. In searching Jason Worley, DeFranco's audience came across the outcome of that advice and informed the YouTuber, who filmed a video offering his support. In the ensuing publicity, the JasonInHell Reddit profile was deleted. One day, a post appeared on the RelationshipAdvice subreddit by a user going by the name
这篇帖子没有引起Philip DeFranco的注意，但他的观众注意到了，并查看了Jason的Reddit个人资料，在那里他们发现了之前他寻求关于出轨妻子建议的帖子。Jason最初说他为了孩子留在妻子身边，但用户一致告诉他要和她离婚。他表达了对这些建议的感激，并打算遵循这些建议。在搜索Jason Worley时，DeFranco的观众发现了这些建议的结果，并通知了这位YouTuber，他拍摄了一段视频表示支持。在随后的宣传中，JasonInHell的Reddit个人资料被删除了。一天，一位名为
JasonInCode, titled, An Update From JasonInHell, that was Jason Worley, who explained, titled An Update from Jason in Hell, it was Jason Worley who explained, I deleted the Jason in Hell account in a knee-jerk reaction to seeing my Reddit posts in the news. I guess the first question to answer is how am I doing, and to that I would say I am doing well. He went on to describe the defeating bad days in which he had used alcohol to avoid nightmares of his children's final moments The support given by friends and family had been fundamental, enabling Jason to drop the habit before it caused too much damage He had also received treatment in hospital for suicidal thoughts that emerged following his children's murders. Jason wrote, From that, I learned that you should never be ashamed of your mental health, and not seeking treatment will only make it worse, not better.
JasonInCode的用户在RelationshipAdvice子版块发布了一篇帖子，标题为“来自JasonInHell的更新”，是Jason Worley解释道：“我删除了JasonInHell的账户，这是看到我的Reddit帖子出现在新闻中后的本能反应。我想第一个要回答的问题是我过得怎么样，对此我会说我过得很好。”他接着描述了那些他曾利用酒精来逃避孩子最后时刻噩梦的失败日子。朋友和家人提供的支持至关重要，使Jason在造成太大伤害之前戒掉了这个习惯。他还因孩子被谋杀后出现的自杀念头在医院接受了治疗。Jason写道：“从那以后，我学到你不应该为自己的心理健康感到羞耻，不寻求治疗只会让情况变得更糟，而不是更好。”
It hadn't been easy. Jason hadn't sought help initially, which led to him losing his job and becoming a recluse. He assured readers not to worry, he had since returned to work and had nearly regained his former position and salary. However, his in-laws were an ongoing problem. They owned the house that Jason and Brandy lived in and had changed the locks shortly after the murders, with Jason's belongings still inside. He tried to negotiate the return of his property, but was accused of theft and told he had to pay to retrieve his belongings. Jason had to get law enforcement involved, but Brandy's family continued to make his life difficult. When Jason visited his children's grave on the one-year anniversary of their murders, his ex-wife's family sat in their truck and watched him the whole time.
这并不容易。Jason最初没有寻求帮助，这导致他失去了工作并变得孤僻。他向读者保证不用担心，他已经重返工作岗位，几乎恢复了以前的职位和薪水。然而，他的岳父母是一个持续存在的问题。他们拥有Jason和Brandy居住的房子，并在谋杀案发生后不久更换了锁，而Jason的财物还在里面。他试图协商取回他的财产，但被指控盗窃，并被告知必须付费才能取回他的财物。Jason不得不让执法部门介入，但Brandy的家人继续让他的生活变得困难。当Jason在孩子被谋杀一周年纪念日去扫墓时，他前妻的家人坐在他们的卡车里，全程盯着他看。
Jason wrote, Because of that, I don't visit the grave as often as I would like to. Because of that, I don't visit the grave as often as I would like to. In regards to how he felt about Brandy's sentencing, Jason explained, That is harder to answer because no matter what the sentence, nothing will bring back my beloved children. Do I think she should have gotten the death penalty, which Indiana has? No, I do not. She wanted to die, and after nine years of giving her what she wanted when she wanted it,
Jason写道：“因为这个原因，我没有像我希望的那样经常去扫墓。”关于他对Brandy量刑的感受，Jason解释说：“这更难回答，因为无论判决如何，都无法带回我心爱的孩子们。我认为她应该被判死刑吗（印第安纳州有死刑）？不，我不认为。她想死，而在九年里，当她想要什么时我就给她什么，
I was not going to give her another thing. Do I think the life sentence will have any appreciable effect on her? I don't know. One thing she always stressed for the entire time that I knew her was that she lived her life without any regrets. Even after I caught her cheating on me, she continued to say she had no regrets. Jason Inhell's Reddit history has been archived on RelationshipAdvice, where it remains locked in time. The posts and original comment threads can be viewed, but nothing else can be changed or added. The subreddit has since reflected on the lessons learned through Jason Worley's ordeal. Users who seek out his original posts are greeted with a message explaining that those who contributed to discussions at the time
我不会再给她任何东西了。我认为终身监禁会对她产生任何明显的影响吗？我不知道。在我认识她的整个时间里，她一直强调的一件事是，她活得没有任何遗憾。即使在我发现她出轨后，她仍然说她没有任何遗憾。”JasonInHell的Reddit历史记录已在RelationshipAdvice上存档，并被锁定在时间里。帖子和原始评论线程可以查看，但不能更改或添加任何内容。该子版块此后反思了通过Jason Worley的磨难所学到的教训。寻找他原始帖子的用户会看到一条消息，解释说当时参与讨论的人
failed to consider the reality of the situation as best as they could have known. Hindsight is 20-20 and encourages users to realise the potential for complications which might make any advice difficult to follow. It ends with the remark, Something which seems obvious to any one of us is rarely ever obvious to someone in the weeds of the relationship itself. Redditors have rallied behind Jason in the aftermath of the murders, with his update post filled with comments expressing support and sympathy. Despite his loss, Jason expressed gratitude to the Relationship Advice community and the service they provide to those in need, adding,
未能尽可能地考虑到现实情况。事后诸葛亮总是容易的，该消息鼓励用户意识到可能存在的复杂性，这可能会使任何建议都难以遵循。结尾处写道：“对我们任何一个人来说显而易见的事情，对于身处关系泥潭中的人来说却很少是显而易见的。”在谋杀案发生后，Reddit用户团结在Jason身后，他的更新帖子中充满了表达支持和同情的评论。尽管遭受了损失，Jason还是对“关系建议”社区以及他们为有需要的人提供的服务表示感谢，并补充道：
No one could have foreseen the tragedy that resulted from me filing for divorce. No one could have foreseen the tragedy that resulted from me filing for divorce. There is one thing in particular that continues to haunt Jason. On the night of the murders, Brandy suggested that he sleep in the living room. In an online post, Jason lamented, I just can't help but wonder that if I had slept on the couch like she had suggested, instead of an air mattress in the basement, then maybe I could have saved my children, or at the very least, died with them.
“没有人能预见到我提出离婚会导致这样的悲剧。”有一件事特别让Jason挥之不去。在谋杀案发生的那个晚上，Brandy建议他睡在客厅里。在一篇在线帖子中，Jason感叹道：“我只是忍不住想，如果我像她建议的那样睡在沙发上，而不是睡在地下室的充气床垫上，那么也许我就能救我的孩子，或者至少和他们一起死。”
A father has one job in this world, to protect his children, and I failed to do that. In his final Reddit post to Relationship Advice, Jason Worley wrote, If I can impart on you something I have learned through all of this, it is that you should always take the time to be with the ones you love. It doesn't matter if they are asking you to read The Pokey Little Puppy for the millionth time or asking you to play Smash Brothers, even though you both know they will wipe the floor with you every time. Just do it, because you never know what time will be the last time. Always make sure they know how much you love them.
一个父亲在这个世界上只有一份工作，那就是保护他的孩子，而我没能做到这一点。在给“关系建议”的最后一篇Reddit帖子中，Jason Worley写道：“如果我能向你们传达我通过这一切所学到的东西，那就是你应该总是花时间和你爱的人在一起。无论他们是让你第无数次读《小狗波基》，还是让你玩《任天堂明星大乱斗》，即使你们都知道他们每次都会把你打得落花流水。去做吧，因为你永远不知道哪一次会是最后一次。一定要让他们知道你有多爱他们。”
I had the fortune that the last thing my children ever heard me say was, I love you, good night. I will see you in the morning. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
“我很幸运，我的孩子们听到的最后一句话是：‘我爱你们，晚安。明天见。’谢谢。”本集节目暂无评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。